[Music]
[Music]
do you enjoy watching innocent people
suffer yeah let me get me the wall Oh
mal your mother would be so proud of you
you took down the barrier and became the
queen of the world but wait a second
where is your mother you sort of ditched
her in descendants too and never looked
back are you going to help her shed her
lizard skin or let her figure things out
on her own we've put our money on the
second option after all you're super
busy now that you have a kingdom to run
and a wedding to plan the people have
spoken and they want to send in Spore
because as it turns out fans still have
a lot of questions that need answering
watch until the end to find out who the
new core for would be new leading ladies
mal has always been the star of the show
but now that she's set to become queen
someone else should take her place as
the coolest BK at auradon prep we could
think of no one better than dizzy
Tremaine it's no secret that dizzy is a
fan favorite problem is we hardly got to
see her in descendants 3 we loved how
close dizzy and Celia were which is why
fans would love it if d4 centered around
these two leading ladies they would make
mal and EB so proud the new wave we
never got to see the B case graduate
from auradon prep which is a total
bummer we would love to see the V case
in a case throw their caps up in
celebration if there's one thing fans
would love to see in descendants 4 it's
a new wave of vks in a K's walking the
halls at auradon prep there are so many
interesting characters we never got to
meet on the small screen keep watching
to find out which magical sisters would
make their grand debut in descendents 4
I was hoping you were home
is this a joke Audrey's bow now has been
Carlos has jeans
he has Doug and Jay has Lani and Gil but
what about the queen of mean fans have
been wondering about
Audrey's future boyfriend ever since
they saw her flirting with Harry hook at
the end of descendants three we all know
that Audrey hasn't been the nicest
person but she wants to change so we
really want to see her get the happily
ever after she always dreamed of and
let's face it
chad charming isn't the guy of her
dreams has anyone seen Maleficent the
question on everyone's lips is what
happened to Maleficent surely the most
powerful sorceress of all time won't be
married to her lizard body for much
longer
fans want to see Maleficent make a grand
comeback in d4 it would be so
interesting to see mal and her mom face
off for a second time Maleficent would
undoubtedly be squeamish after spending
so much time as a reptile do you think
she would forgive mal or seek revenge on
her daughter's newfound Kingdom tell us
in the comments what about uma as it
turns out
uma is as selfless as they come she
sacrificed her freedom to help her
people and didn't garner any titles in
the process we thought that Allah would
be appointed the rightful ruler of the
Isle of the laws but that just didn't
happen we'd love to see whom and mal
working together in descendants for uma
could become one of Mao's royal advisers
and start making a difference for DK's
everywhere we'd also love to see uma
fall in love she may be a former villain
but the pirate still deserves her
happily ever after
Gil and Jai's epic adventure Gil and Jai
totally hit it off midway through
descendants three their bond was so
explosive it was sure to make Harry and
Carlos a little jealous we loved how
they made plans to tour the world but we
sort of wish that we could catch a sneak
peak of their epic adventure how fun
would it be if mal received a magical
postcard from Gil and Jai at the
beginning of d4 they would probably be
surfing on a whale's back with huge
grins on their faces
reunion we know belen beasts are going
to attend Benin mouths wedding but what
about Hades in Maleficent if there's one
musical number we need to see in d4 it's
a duet sung by Hades and Maleficent
Dan's want to get the full scoop on
their relationship they need to know why
and how it came to an end no I left your
mother Hades and Maleficent have some
unfinished business which is why their
duet would be the song of the ages Elsa
and Anna Elsa and Anna are nowhere to be
found
fans would love it if Elsa and Anna had
small roles in descendants for it would
be so fun to see them dropping their
kids off at school and you never know
they might even help dizzy and Celia
form the new core for the merge now that
the barrier has been taken down themes
are going to change in Oregon for good
fans are curious to find out how the
fashion in Oregon will change now that
the V case and a case have merged
together they'd also like to see how the
ak's Envy case interact with one another
have they let bygones be bygones or have
they continued to oppose each other the
royal wedding but the most anticipated
moment of descendants four has to be
Benin mouths royal wedding if d4 doesn't
end up happening fans hope that the
Disney Channel will at least release a
short film of Benin mouths wedding what
do you want to see in descendants for
sound off in the comments
[Music]
sushi definitely teaching okay now we
know you were deeply in love with King
VIN at the end of descendants three but
would you have gone on to have kids with
him or would your VK roots have pulled
you over to Harry hook we know the two
of you have serious chemistry in the
movie and in real life too of course
regardless of which guy you choose in
the end one thing's for sure there's no
keeping that purple hair down your kid
is sure to inherit that what would the
next generation of BK's look like in
descendants for we're imagining all the
key couples kids as well as other
pairings that might have gotten together
keep watching to the end to discover
which unlikely couple would have an
awesome looking kid plenty of fans have
been shipping them mal and then we're
starting with the biggest V kak Alliance
in the whole franchise and we can just
imagine Malin been with an adorable
daughter Finn has hazel eyes and mal of
course has striking green eyes so it's
pretty much a given that their little
girl would follow in those footsteps as
for hair color
we can't help to think that this little
one will take after her mom of course
mal has gone through different shades
from blonde to blue but purple is her
signature hue mal and Terry there's no
denying there's chemistry between mal
and Harry hook and with dove Cameron and
Thomas Doherty dating in real life let's
have a little fun with art imitating
life
what if mal and Ben broke up and mal and
Harry had a kid we see these two v case
having a son and he'd be a mix of his
parents ki looks with his dad's dark
hair this little boy would represent his
mom with an awesome purple streak right
through it of course he'd wear guyliner
just like his dad and his granddad Hades
Audrey and Harry when it comes to Harry
mom might have competition on her hands
from a K turns VK turned a keg and
Audrey after all Audrey and Harry got a
little friendly at the end of d3 imagine
if they had a little girl we'd love to
see Audrey spell pink and blue streaks
in mini-me form on her daughter but what
was she inherit from her pirate father
his love of ruffle collars and leather
of course Evy and Doug V's blue hair is
her signature look so we can't imagine
her daughter with Doug having anything
other than blueberry locks
given that Doug grew out his hair to
epic lengths in d3 we are certain that
their kid would have a following mane -
but this little girl would inherent
something special from her daddy
gorgeous green eyes how cute would it be
from mal and Evie's daughters to be
green eye twins she'd be super well
dressed in blue and red - thanks to her
fashion designer mother Evie and Carlos
so many descendants fans shipped Evie
and Carlos so we have to imagine what
their little boy would look like don't
you think Carlos's white hair would look
amazing with Evie's blue hair showing
through at the roots we'd also love to
see Carlos's freckles being inherited by
his son with Evie with their dark brown
eyes being passed on to their boy he'd
be totally striking Jane and Carlos
Carlos was actually head over heels in
love with Jane of course so the
likelihood is that this couple would go
the distance we see them having a little
girl who would dress in lacy blue
outfits just like her mom their daughter
would inherit Jane's beautiful blue eyes
- she'd have her daddy's hair though
just imagine Carlos's white locks on a
girl all the way down to her waist truly
stunning you just got a man up Jay and
money
there's no way Jay and Lonnie's children
wouldn't have long dark locks just look
at their parents we could see this
couple having a boy and a girl and these
siblings would have matching Mane's as
their dad has proven boys can rock man
buns so they could wear their hair and
matching styles and they would totally
Rock red leather outfits to represent
their grandfather Jafar dizzy and
squeaky squeaky would likely have twins
but rather than boys he'd have identical
girls and we'd love to see him having
those twins with fellow BK dizzy
Tremaine but how would they tell their
kids apart well that'd be thanks to
their mom's mad hairdressing skills Oh
this or today pink just like Dizzy's
multicolored space buns these girls
would have their own cool style that one
would have blue and green streaks while
the other would have red and yellow
streaks that's against the bright blonde
hair they'd have inherited from their
dad Celia and squirmy
as for squirmy his son would rock a pair
of black frames eyeglasses like a cool
geek we're matching squirmy with the
other d3v case celia and we could see
her curly red hair being passed on to
her little boy combined with his dad's
red beanie hand-me-down this kid would
be rocking the red look all over luma
and bin are you shipping venon uma if so
you're going to love with their kid
would look like we can't imagine their
son with anything other than aqua blue
thoughts tied back and like his dad he'd
wear a royal blue shirt he'd be one
amazing mashup of a pirate and a king
the rest of the B Ches better beware
this boy is ready to rule our zon and
the Isle
congratulations on your engagement now
you're going to be the best Queen
auradon has ever seen it's a new chapter
for auradon and the Isle of the Lost
you and Ben will be so happy together
but we want to know what happens next
what is your wedding going to be like
what happens to Carlos we have so many
questions and we want answers descendant
3 was epic but we already want more if
there was a descendant for a movie what
would it be about keep watching for some
fan theories that make total sense the
Royal Wedding
move over William and Kate step aside
Harry and Megan there is only one royal
wedding that we really care about
we want to see Malin then get married we
want to see the wedding gown that Evie
designs and we definitely want to know
who Mouse bridesmaids will be Evie is
obviously her maid of honor but do you
think Huma and Jane will be her
bridesmaids and let's be honest we
definitely want to see the moment that
mal officially becomes Queen of auradon
and the aisle some fans have suggested
that descendants four could open with a
royal wedding others have suggested that
Disney Channel could really
so short film of just the wedding we
wonder if Maleficent would come Mao
would have to turn her back into a human
since we're pretty sure she's still a
lizard the new vks descendants three
brought four new villain kids to auradon
those were dizzy Tremaine Celia facili a
and squeaky and squirmy Smee the core
four have moved on from their time at a
word on prep descendants four could
focus on these four new vks Celia is
definitely the ringleader and dizzy is
going to bring a whole new level of
fashion to the school we would love to
see more about these characters plus the
barrier is now permanently open auradon
prep will get a lot more vks it would be
awesome to see how auradon prep changes
with all the new kids they will have new
challenges and new adventures that the
original four didn't have honestly a
movie about Celia and dizzy would be
absolutely amazing the next generation
here's another popular theory for
descendants floor what if the movie
takes place in the distant future we
could see the kids of mal and Ben who
would be Prince and princesses it would
be fun to see if they are tough like mal
or kind like been growing up with Hades
as your grandpa would be a blast Doug
and Easy's kids would be the perfect
combination of smart and stylish Evie
would have upgraded from her starter
castle to a really nice one their kids
would be BFFs with Mouse children we
could find out if Jay ends up with
Lonnie or not will oh my get married and
have kids or will she be the cool aunt
to Mouse family and will Harry and
Audrey end up together
their kids would be the perfect
antagonist in descendants for hopefully
they would learn how to be good just
like their parents did what about Carlos
the whole world was devastated with the
loss of Cameron boys he was definitely
taken too soon if Disney ever made a
descendants for it they would have to
address the fact that Carlos is gone it
wouldn't be fair to just recast him so
what happens to Carlos the most obvious
way to explain his absence is actually
mentioned in descendants three he says
that his mom Cruella will be really
disappointed when she finds out that he
wants to be a vet he could be off that
veterinarian school it takes a long time
to become the vet you have to get your
bachelor's degree first which takes four
to five years and then that school is
another four years that's at least eight
years that Carlos will have to be away
from Oregon he could also go off to
rescue animals after vet school - in our
hearts
Carlos is forever so we would love for
descendants forward to mention Carlos
and Jane throughout the film life with
the villains now that the barrier is
open forever there is a whole new set of
issues magic will now work on the Isle
of the Lost and the villains who were
imprisoned there can come to Oregon that
is going to cause some serious conflict
King Ben and Queen mal definitely have
their work cut out for them so maybe all
the villains aren't that bad Katie's
just wants to be god of the underworld
again he really came through for Malin
or it on at the end so we won't have to
worry about him dr. facili a is a really
great dad we think his love for Celia
will keep him honest but what about the
rest of the villains Cruella De Vil and
Maleficent are not nice people and we
never met some of the villains like
Captain Hook and Ursula we have a hard
time believing that they'll all decide
to behave since banishing and
imprisoning people on the Isle isn't an
option anymore Ben and mal will have to
find other ways to keep the people of
auradon save maybe they'll make a
rehabilitation center for the villains
who are having a hard time being good it
would be so cool to see how auradon and
the Isle mesh together in the brand new
world Ben and mal have created so what
do you guys think is the story really
over and what would you want to see in
descendants board
tell us in the comments how could you
forget what she did to us how could you
forget that I was supposed to be your
grade you will go you will find the
fairy godmother and you will bring me
back her magic wand
easy peasy could Maleficent and Audrey
team up in descendants for you and
Maleficent have a lot in common Audrey
it's almost as if you're the daughter
she's always wanted how ironic is that
it's really too bad that Maleficent is
still stuck in her lizard form if you
could find a way to change her back you
could work together to boot Mel off the
throne it's a win-win really we just
hope you fight your evil days behind you
or out smell will rue the day that she
ever stepped foot in auradon Maleficent
and Audrey have a common enemy but will
that be enough for them to team up in
descendants for if T forever happens
we'd love to see Audrey and Maleficent
join forces and attempt to take over
auradon keep watching to find out which
major clue from descendants three hinted
towards Audrey and Maleficent working
together with the way things ended in
descendants three you would never
suspect that Audrey still had a bone to
pick with Ben and mal but we're not
buying Audrey's good girl act and want
to hurt you both I wanted to hurt all of
you but let's be real she wanted to hurt
them long before that Audrey was shocked
when Ben proposed - mal so much so that
she went to steal the Queen's crown from
the museum then and mal finally
apologized to Audrey when Hades saved
her but their apology was long overdue
Audrey might feel bad about what she did
but she still wants to be the queen and
mal is still living the life that Audrey
always wanted so her good girl Act is
bound to fade sooner than later
Audrey literally screamed when Ben
proposed to Mouse so imagine what she'll
do when the lovers exchange I Do's
Audrey will probably receive an invite
to the wedding which is almost as bad as
not being invited at all she'll be
forced to watch the man of her dreams
marry someone else but you know who
won't be invited to the wedding
Maleficent mouths very own mother we
know for a fact that Maleficent doesn't
like being left off the guest list so we
wouldn't be surprised at the little
evil lizard slithered her way into
Audrey's thoughts what better way to
stop a wedding than to let Maleficent
crash it
but finding Maleficent and turning her
back into an evil fairy won't be easy
luckily for Audrey she and Maleficent
are fated to team up and even out the
score Maleficent terrorized Audrey's
family so she would be the last person
Audrey went to for help right well not
exactly
The Descendants franchise has a knack
for irony so Audrey and Maleficent could
very well end up working together after
all
Edie ended up falling in love with Doug
who's the son of one of her mom's sworn
enemies it takes a very special person
to work with Maleficent and Maleficent
is known for going solo she's got some
major trust issues and only really
trusts her pet raven diablo and her
scepter dragon's eye but for some
strange reason her scepter called out to
audrey when she crossed paths with it
the most surprisingly the scepter let
Audrey use it without condemning her to
1000 years of sleep so clearly Audrey
and Maleficent share a special bond
after all now walked by that very same
scepter in that very same Museum and it
never called out to her what makes
Audrey and Maleficent even better allies
is that they both have common goals
first and foremost Maleficent wants to
get revenge on mal who totally betrayed
her in the first Descendants movie
obviously mal made the right choice but
she did keep her mom as a pet lizard
instead of returning her to the aisle
both Maleficent and Audrey want to show
mal who's boss and they most definitely
aren't okay with her ruling over auradon
and the Isle of the Lost after what she
did to them we just hope that Maleficent
doesn't want to be queen because that
would put Audrey and Maleficent at odds
the first thing Audrey would need to do
is get her hands on Maleficent scepter
again then she could use it to locate
Maleficent and undo the spell that
turned her into the lizard in the first
place then Audrey could fill Maleficent
in on the last year's events and they
could plan to ruin mal and Ben's wedding
since Audrey still wants to be liked by
the people of auradon it's in her best
interest to act innocent once Mouse out
of the picture Audrey could put a love
spell on Ben and caught her way onto the
throne Maleficent always feared that mal
wasn't evil enough she pushed mal to
commit terrible crimes and saw her
daughter's good nature get in the way
time and time again that's a problem
she'll never have with Audrey Audrey has
been a mean girl since day one she takes
what she thinks she deserves and lashes
out when things don't go as planned
Audrey is the daughter Maleficent always
wanted and together they could come
close to taking over auradon we can
already imagine the look on everyone's
face when Maleficent crashes her
daughter's wedding just like she did at
Aurora's christening the fact that
Maleficent scepter chose Audrey has to
mean something
Audrey will stop at nothing to be the
queen of auradon
but if usurping mal is on her agenda
Maleficent and audrey better succeed
no it's ands or buts because if they
fail mal won't hesitate to turn both of
them into lizards and let her future
children keep them as pets do you think
Audrey is done with being the queen of
mean
or will she strike again on Ben and
Mouse wedding day sound off in the
comments thanks for watching we hope you
enjoyed our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things we'll catch you
next time
you